wow
dieses produkt ist momentan leider nicht
auf lager flügels zu deiner wunschliste
ein super los
man kann den look funtastic
adventskalender auf ebay kaufen für 180
euro und original hatte 95 euro kostet
ich habe den pilz full bestellt aber da
ein bisschen gebraucht sehr hart server
geht es dir so krass nicht mehr
[Musik]
ausverkauft man kriegt es auch gar keine
infos mehr dazu jetzt fühle ich mich
schon ein bisschen besser man auch die
dann gekauft haben 39 habe ich den
gestellt ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
kenne glück fantastic nicht da ich jetzt
im intro schon hunderte male kritik
gesagt habe
das video ist nicht geschockt ich habe
95 euro dafür ausgegeben und kann gar
nicht abwarten die produkte darin zu
entdecken dazu bin ich auch für meine
verhältnisse sehr minimal geschminkt und
heute lassen wir die tube mal beiseite
ich weiß ich weiß ich mag für den einen
oder anderen ein wenig arrogant im
letzten video rübergekommen sei dafür
möchte ich mich an dieser stelle noch
einmal herzlich bei euch entschuldigen
dann kümmern sich nur herzlich oder
entschuldigt man sie auch hierzu ja was
ich sagen möchte sich wollte niemanden
auf schlips treten und ich glaube viele
haben mich ein bisschen falsch
verstanden dafür versuche ich heute mich
so korrekt wie möglich auszudrücken
damit auch jeder weiß wie ich etwas
meine ich will ja bloß nicht überheblich
rüberkommt macht denn schon wieder meine
tasche hier machen
sorry mit diesen schlechten wird
eigentlich sagen wollte ich wurde auch
nicht mit dem goldenen löffel im mund
geboren ich bin jetzt auch nicht der
vertreter von ich habe alles so hart
gearbeitet und deswegen hab ich auch
alles verdient ich finde man könnte
einiges besser machen was gehälter
angeht von berufen die wichtig für
unsere gesellschaft sind wichtiger als
ein influenza auch wenn ich das nicht
mag diesen begriff ich kann halt nix
dafür wie das leben ist ein statement
jetzt hier nicht ganz ehrlich rüber ich
habe auf instagram hat schon soviel
darüber gesprochen dass ich das gefühl
habe es schon gesagt zu haben so wie wir
gerade erfahren haben ist dieser
adventskalender wohl der absolute
heißeste scheiß ich konnte schon einmal
reinschauen und muss sagen dass ich ihn
optisch schon mal sehr elegant für
türchen wechseln sich mit einem matten
und glänzenden schwarz ab die zahlen
sind
außer die 1 das ist unser goldenes
natürlich etwas gefühl ist wirklich ein
sehr heiß begehrter adventskalender ich
hatte das nicht so auf dem schirm
einpacken ihnen jetzt mal aus weil die
haare so halbwegs hoch versuche heute so
viel wie möglich von den produkten auch
zu benutzen ohne komplett bildung und
dann fangen wir an mit türchen nummer
eins ich weiß gar nicht was drin sein
könnte das waren ganz schön großes
tüchern für ein so ein kleines ding was
ist dieses kleine einmal diese haare
nicht gemacht weil ich so weil ich hätte
mich nicht fertigmachen
das ist somit die idee war meine art zu
machen
google denn die kameraden für mich
einfach eigentlich als eine halbe stunde
später
das ist natürlich nur 1/3
adventskalender natascha denn ohne diese
marke kennt ich sogar weil ich ihn
highlighter davon habe dieses am
expensive steht ich habe ja schon den
highlighter genau von der markt das
werde ich jetzt nicht aufmachen weil ich
werde das ein paar mal benutzten ich
habe nämlich eine palette und lieben uns
ja nicht ganz gerne weil so das wird auf
jeden fall verlost
mega cool ich glaube dieser
adventskalender wird wieder so dreimal
seinen preis wert sein oh warte nur ab
werther zuhörer aber mein hirn kann das
gerade noch nicht verarbeiten und der
preis war 95 euro nummer zwei ich
vermute lang sein dass das echten
krasser transponder ist kann die marke
luk sutil hinwil ich habe gestern erst
alle meine pinsel gewaschen also so
richtig dann ist mir aufgefallen wie
viele ich eigentlich hab darüber freut
sich bestimmt jemand lux ii blieb stabil
aus made in volksrepublik china ich
merke dass ich voll verhalten bin mit
dem was ich sagen möchte kannst alles
sagen was du sagen willst 3000 daumen
nach unten machen dich nicht kaputt 2000
daumen nach unten machen dich nicht
fertig sanierte serviette vanessa das
ist ein sehr gut aus wie das luxuriöse
spiel was ich als konsument in england
das ich nie von innen gesehen habe so
ritz carlton mäßig sollte anfangen die
preise zu checken
das macht irgendwie am meisten spaß auf
ok das duschgel wollten braun 7 euro 50
für 100 milliliter duschgel geil
und shower gel das heißt man kann sich
das in die badewanne machen und man kann
sich damit waschen
die gehört sorge ich habe eine badewanne
und liebe baden nicht machen
rhabarber und rose ich bin eigentlich
nicht so der fan von süßen dürften und
der ist irgendwie süß euro ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl zu fassen wer teure
geländer wird natascha bellona euro 5
so jetzt geht es ans kirchen immer viele
leute es jetzt in die kommentare
teure produkte sind dragons plot klingt
das habe ich
in tonic tonic gesichts tonic dragons
blatt cleansing bord aha also das
rosenwasser und föderation und so ein
shit drin
er hat diesen punkt bin ich immer so
cool wenn man nur so seien wattepads
drauf macht ihr habt ja dann benutzen
das denn das ist mega sogar
augen-make-up her bin ich gespannt ich
mal auf 100 milliliter 19 eur 45 im
augen-make-up acts natürlichen nummer 5
und wir sind jetzt schon bei 57 euro
dürfte können ja auch teurer sein aber
müssen ja da nicht dadurch automatisch
viel besser sein aber das alleine crazy
das ist zu viel kostet ihn immer
verfügen die kripo ein cremiger
eyeshadow gepreist 10 euro und kann
damit tolle phase mehr machen
das praktischerweise einem cream eine
schere und man braucht nicht mal
einpinseln
[Musik]
wählen sie einfach immer auf sleep drauf
das hat die perfekte farbe ich hoffe man
sieht also ich habe jetzt nur auf speed
drauf getragen aber warum ist es halt
wirklich das schnellste wie man sich
schminken kann da ein bisschen mit dem
finger um malen und dann fertig saniert
des nikolaus und lockt fantastic denkt
natürlich an nikolaus und sagt hey war
das fröhlich nikolaus irgendwie sieht es
sehr sehr edel aus ich weiß nicht warum
sie denken nicht an dich glaubst also
glaubt philipp kingsley die conditioning
treatment ich rieche nichts also ein
conditioner aber so eine maske die
forscher führt hertha also das ist so
eine richtig richtig intensive h maske
die man irgendwie auch nur mit seinen
fingerspitzen so benutzen soll aus
england will natürlich verlost so
übrigens das ist das erste das geländer
video was ich im november drehe jetzt
fühlt sich das auch so richtig an als ob
ich das dürfte vorher ich mich ein
bisschen wie ein betrüger gefühlt aber
jetzt haben wir mal sieben auch immer
dieses preise suchen ich mein ich finde
es interessant am ende zu wissen wie
viel das kostet das wie gemacht dass mit
den preisen suchen sind aber ich habe
keine lust das machen
viel spaß damit leute so jetzt zu sieben
rennen cleanskin ready steady glow aha
ich zu sehr offen sagt aha so nicht
eigentlich aus es ist einfach pflegen
tonic water was man nach dem waschen
benutzen pflegend und soll die anglo
verleihen ist eine probier größe denke
ich oder dass mir das mit fünf euro
einschätzen dass die suche nach außen
neuen lidschatten paletten die kann also
die kann man viele besitzen aber ich
habe jetzt schon so viele tolle
gesichtswasser also das ist jetzt halt
für mich nur noch nicht dass sie es so
ok noch eins weil ich ab jetzt keine
hautpflegeserie an die ich so schwörer
zwingen bin ich bei allen happy deswegen
feiert jetzt auch keine haut serie so
unbedingt davon sagt mein gott wir sind
jetzt willkommen ein ja was ist das
krienser creme interessante farbe ist
original die außenems paar who also das
klingt hier wie eine super interessante
art sich sauber zu machen also das zeug
ihm ins gesicht einräumen warmes
handtuch und dann wird es wahrscheinlich
1 ist ja interessant 20 milliliter 15
euro das gebe ich euch mal probiert es
mal aus verpackungsmaterial diego della
valle
die pens tisch ist ein kajalstift tut
ich habe wirklich viele geschäfte
deswegen werde ich denen nicht mal
benutzten am sorry
er ist aus italien 16 eur 45
also nur mal so wir sind ja jetzt schon
über den preis stimme bezahlt haben wie
nummer 10
ich liebe richards
aber ich glaube das ist das neue basic
beach boys und cherry blossom body scrub
damit kann ich meinen bodies meine
freundin nicht nicht anders gut so dann
nehmen wir uns mal ein bisschen von
diesem paradies ok ich verrate ich jetzt
trick 17 zum einschlafen kurze gucken
wenn diese frauen immer so eingecremt
werden
dann werden den ganzen tag da diese
hände eingerieben
also mit diesem paradies klappt ist
meine haut und zehn jahre jünger
wenn sie schnell sind dann können auch
sie heute noch ihre erste body scrub
gewünschten features kaufen rät sehen
wie man sich ein gutes gefühl während
dieser lockdown phase macht hat sie die
möglichkeit habt ein bad wenn ich
einfach in die badewanne sondern macht
gibt euch eine kopfmassage cremt euch
danach gut ein
macht so ein zucker peeling vielleicht
macht ihr noch broicher stäbchen an oder
ganz verrückt euren lieblings t ihr
körper freut sich ich kann mich gar
nicht beschreiben wie gut es riecht aber
was mich wundert ist wie erfolgreich
unsere schuld sein
das ist überall diese lieben plötzlich
von ja ok marge sogar unbezahlbar das
ist werden jetzt sieben euro 7 euro für
das body scrub
was ich gerne die uns ja auch hätte so
einen auch vielleicht einfach nur privat
einen esoterik adventskalender libertäre
das ist sehr klein cell fernseher um
also trage vier bis zwölf tropfen direkt
auf deine haut einmassieren leute machen
mal den halb so gut an so soll jetzt
merken wir da aus sind selbstbräuner
eigentlich noch so cool im letzten
adventskalender war auch ein
selbstbräuner drin aber ich hab'
selbstbräuner so gar nicht mehr
angekommen
ich halte ihn einfach nicht aus masco
rainer kostet zehn euro es ist made in
der volksrepublik china
mich schreckt es immer schon ein
bisschen ab wenn ich made in china sehe
gerade bei solchen produkten weil china
halt andere voraussetzungen dass
tierversuche in so etwas angeht hat aber
ich würde es dann noch mal ausprobieren
so nagellack nail polish kenne ich aber
symbolisch habe den begriff noch nie
gehört also in dieser barcode macht mich
fertig dass die deutschen gerne fand sie
auch hier ist meine e lamassoure werbung
in la masia
polish ich liebe ihn hatten
leichengeruch aber ich kann sagen wissen
wofür ich würde ich sagen er macht die
lippen auf jeden fall crazy girl
verwundert wie schnell das gerade
irgendwie den bann zieht einmal rüber
und er war drauf und dann war so ok ich
meine vielleicht das chorjahr wohnen
geheimtipp von dem ich nichts weiß nun
schreibt es mir gerne in die kommentare
wenn ihr sagt oh mein gott du können
vieler moskva lippenstifte nicht vanessa
ist doch grundschul wissen dann machen
wir weiter mit nächstes türen
was war da haben die reingestopft
erschüttert und da meine damen und
herren 13 14
eine schlafmaske schlafmasken und ganz
ehrlich wieviel schlafmasken kann man
gebrauchen also ganz so die hat mich
fast jetzt nicht die hat so ein bändchen
hier sind echt sehr schön aus rechne ich
jetzt mit fünf euro war ich glaube ich
werde mir für die verlosung richtig so
versuchen themen auszudenken ich muss
mich da jetzt langsam daran setzen also
entweder werde ich adventskalender
verlosen also die abwärtswelle
ausgepackt habe neu befüllen und das
sind verlosen weil das aber glaube ich
sehr aufwendig sein wird werde ich
wahrscheinlich pakete machen also
geschenke an diesem punkt ist uns
eigentlich noch verbeugen und danke
sagen dass wir unseren preis zu
ökologie dating oxygen die winkel also
eine creme für alte leute zehn
milliliter von dieser creme kosten 25
euro
da sind 30 drin
cool danke look von traffic wirklich
sehr cool wie jetzt macht das irgendwie
gar keinen will also 75 euro
ich sag mal so habe das
weihnachtsgeschenk an alina ich hab sie
selber gekauft sie waren in einem
adventskalender drin
nein ich bin in einen laden gegangen und
habe gesagt mensch diese creme für 75
euro
das schreit alina happy birthday wenn
man von dieser creme nicht mindestens
zehn jahre jünger wird nicht mit mir
manchmal hat man tage da kann man keinen
kopf tragen beide häuser ja ich fertig
bin einfach nicht mehr kreativ mit
menschen so was sagt uns die 15
und an alle die gefragt haben ich weiß
nicht was für ein bild kalender ich
dieses jahr haben werde
also nicht von dieser marke aber ich
habe schon gehört dass man vitamin c
zero benutzen soll ist die marke aber es
ist doch 20 milliliter wie viel es hier
drin 10 alle die hälfte 24 euro vier
größere ja 24 euro für diese probleme
größe recht
das ist das was so grassiert gerochen
hat sleeps liebt das ist was zum
einschlafen blieb's liebt die kokojty
tasking bio die sleep cycle für ben haim
ramon ich glaube die firma die das
produziert das werk des werks gehen wir
dieses produkt x an das ist geschlossen
und riecht so intensiv das liegt einfach
schon so nach so einem spa lavendel
schlaf geruch visum massagestudio also
man soll das vor dem schlafengehen auf
seine hände und seinen körper mein gott
das ist pures lavendel extrem schläfrig
gerade und creme stelle ich mir wirklich
ans bett und immer wenn ich abends
schlafen gehe würde ich mir die hände
heben wie so eine amerikanische mutter
und werden noch mit timo mit reden über
den tag und was unsere pläne für den
nächsten sind ätherische öle sollen
einem jahr auch helfen beim schlafen und
gerade so der geruch von lavendel
es hilft schon echt ganz gut beim
entspannen und 20 euro
ich meine aber achtung fertig
ich werde jetzt echt ich falls gerade
richtig sparsam 17 ein wunder dass der
schon ausverkauft ist wirklich jetzt
wundert mich nicht warum ist das so
es macht mir schon wieder angst dass
kingsley homophobie zafira meine hände
riechen jahres eine deep sleep body
cream kostet 15 euro
ich wollte euch gerade hinhalten sie
rechtsmedizinisch also nicht wie so eine
dekorative seid ihr versteht was ich
meine sondern so eine creme soho die
macht etwas dies hilft ich glaube dass
ich mal meine schwester probieren aber
die muss auch noch mal also ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher wie das jetzt hier
funktionieren soll also eine masse macht
man die wahrscheinlich drauf und west
dann wieder runter
einheit rating planer von sleep reimer
macht man for make up drauf damit das
make-up besser sitzt und länger hält und
das ist eigentlich ganz gut dass der
auch gleichzeitig für ihr da ist ja 45
19 anastasia beverly hills ist ungefähr
das aargauer augenbrauen produkt von
anastasia jemals benutzt habe schaut
euch mal an wie schön dass ich das ist
jetzt wie augenbrauen aber es ist
anscheinend eine maskerade probiere
größe definitiv ich hatte jetzt so ganz
bisschen schon drauf wenn man keine
chance nicht liebt die euro deutlich je
ein türchen nummer 20 ist quaid body
clans also es ist ein waschbär aber man
spürt es sich einlässt es ganz kurz
eine maske einziehen und dann spielt man
es erst ab was es nicht alles an
produkten gibt also hier wird das als
entgiften der körper reiniger
beschrieben unser klar einiges cage 1 1
du stellst eine erfrischende tägliche
wäsche plus ganzkörper maske die deiner
haut ein geschmeidiges und tiefen
gereinigt das gefühl fährt auf der
gezielten aufgezählten stellen oder im
gesamten körper tragen bevor du für die
ultimative spielerfahrung zu hause in
die badewanne oder unter die dusche
springst oja die riecht die richtig
richtig in spa hatten sie die maske ich
das gut es riecht leicht winzig sehr
natürlich richtig gut
das kostest du türchen nummer 21 langsam
langweilig
dass die sachen teuer sind ist ja cool
aber ich finde cool sein cool als teure
sachen ist ein richtiger wellen ist
adventskalender ich hätte hier richtig
mich komplett eincremen können ich
dachte das ist auch ein bisschen mehr
make up also das ist eine augen falten
die vollkommene antifaltencreme leute
habt ihr schon mal die vollkommene
antifaltencreme gesehen die ich wirklich
vollkommen und weil das eine super
kleine ist fünf euro auf 21 22
ich bin voll dankbar angekommen was für
sein geld erhält viel pflege doch für
den größen so dass wirklich zeit wieso
das sind jetzt auch nach unserer proben
bis zu drei euro also einfach ein
beispiel fürs gesicht okay nein das ist
geändert 25 cad cam nikolaus zürich
herrn 23 da habe ich gelernt das ist
anscheinend das ist eine tolle marke
habt ihr bei der augencreme letztes mal
total fass aufgemacht wo ich das ja
nicht wusste also 50 milliliter kosten
89 euro das sind 50 milliliter 80
das wellness abend macht die nummer 24
ist ja irgendwie ich bin ich offiziell
weihnachten lord und barry perfekt grau
magic pencil die feiner da hole ich doch
mal mein spiegel hier immer durch
bürsten mit dem halt macht etwa jemand
konkurrenz zu
was sagt er ist es okay gewesen
das hat mich jetzt nicht krass umgehauen
aber von jetzt an schlecht geht wie den
jetzt auf 14 euro schätzt das ok traube
würde meine damen und herren türchen
nummer 25
und schon vorhin was für 89 euro da drin
war also okay wir können jetzt schon mal
offiziell sagen dieser adventskalender
war auch wellness und pflege
ausgerichtet und nicht auf make-up ihre
sieht diese creme teurer auch als mein
leben die ist so schwer 55 milliliter
urin ein bisschen komisch habe mir ein
bisschen creme drauf ich bin noch nicht
den preis müssen heute will sie erst mal
benutzen wo meine hand fühlen sich
richtig nass als redner rosmarie und
soll 24 stunden feuchtigkeit spenden
die ganze teuer also okay ich meine die
kostet 59 euro
nur gedacht dass man irgendwie dann
immer so das große finale macht ich gebe
jetzt nochmal plus 59 1 und willkommen
bei einem ergebnis 513 das tut mir leid
leute aber mein hirn kann das gerade
noch nicht verarbeiten in meinem
taschenrechner stets 513 hier steht noch
mal das endergebnis ist wahrscheinlich
so um den dreh raus sich gerade krank
verrechnet und merkst dann im schnitt zu
preis leistung brauchen wir absolut
nichts sagen also ich dachte ein
bisschen mehr dass ein beauty
adventskalenders deswegen habe ich mich
auch nur ein bisschen geschrieben und
wollte mich halt hier während des videos
schminken das hätte jetzt eher so ein
wellness view werden können aber ich bin
ich bin einfach schockiert also an sich
könnte ich auf alles einfach wieder
zurück packen und den auch bei ebay für
200 euro zu kaufen aber ich finde ganz
ehrlich hat man mal die chance so teure
produkte auszuprobieren ich habe schon
mal so ein luxusprodukte video gedreht
da habe ich creme von la mer gehabt und
so eine komische maske mit rötlich und
das hat auch alles irgendwie so viel
gekostet und ich muss sagen ich war
jetzt nicht so zu tode begeistert dass
ich danach angefangen hat mir immer
wieder teure produkte zu kaufen
ich mag meine basics und deswegen ist es
glaube ich eine coole spielerei oder mal
man kann mal reinschauen was ist denn
für übertrieben teure produkte gibt ohne
dass man das alles dafür ausgeben muss
wie gesagt es wundert mich nicht dass
dieser adventskalender ausverkauft ist
es ich finde das preis
leistungsverhältnis gut wenn man eine
kritik sagen darf dann ist es dass da
sehr viele cremes und so drin sind mache
mir jetzt ein schönes paar abend und
werde mich komplett von kopf bis fuß
eincremen bis zum nächsten mal bin ich
fast gestolpert man eine gucci tasche
ist ein bisschen schwer erst mal nur ein
pilz entschuldigung
[Musik]